i
see social media and technology existing
to flatten
society it makes people very boring all
of the experiences kids have right now
are online many of their closest
friendships are online their first
relationships are online
uh the culture is is very homogeneous
and that's i think it's eliminating
characters it's eliminating
interesting people it's making people
into ai
uh all of their teachers yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
charles bukowski as well let's not get
crazy it's not there yet
right i mean the 75 000 dog is not doing
anything
you know so i mean we're not there yet
listen i hate p i get why you like ai so
much i hate people too and i'm very
amenable to ai
and i i agree with you like listen i
think the future we got to get everyone
out of here
i'm with you on that so don't think i'm
i love people he's manipulating my mind
that's why the flash of light in your
eyes when you talked about that dog
was so much more than any person and i
get it by the way you're right i love
people but
if they're not excited if it can just
use robots to kill
most of them i think that would be good
for society
i'm with that too but uh i i think that
social media flattens flattening the
personalities
personalities of people man and it's
just you know when's the last time like
i like the idea of like
you know and i'm you know somebody
showing up to uh
you know high school like a backpack and
taking out an old cd and being like hey
man
here's this band you've never heard of
that i love or whatever you got to get
into this and i'm like
you know when i talk to young you know
friends that have younger brothers and
everything
ever and i know that the dominant
culture was always dominant i'm not an
idiot but like i feel like it's harder
to be unique and original now
because so much of of what's promoted
is just this way to kind of corral
people into believing and thinking
a certain set of ideals that's
constantly shifting and evolving
and people are just caught up in that
and to me
it gets very boring very quickly i hate
being bored
that's what it is i don't know what to
do with that because at the same time
podcasts are really popular long-form
podcasts really popular and people are
people are hungry for those kinds of
conversations there's a lot of dangerous
ideas
quote unquote flowing uh being spread
around
through podcasts meaning just like
debates correct
you know so that's still popular so i
don't know what to
i agree with that gives me hope i guess
i hope so too and like i said i i look
at the negative a lot because that's
what i
usually make fun of but there's a lot of
positive stuff happening too
you